[Music]
okay so hello everyone welcome to my
class grandmaster choice
today's topic is going to be positional
play
so we have some in-person audience
online i'll try to make sure that i'm
answering your question online but also
people who are here so please this class
is for you so do not hesitate to ask any
questions clarifications
you know disagree with me uh
argue i'm all for that place on
um and what we are gonna do today is
um is positional chess so
i when i was younger i always had
troubles with positional chess and i
would be like thinking about plans and
my coach would always like tell me you
have to really think about plans and
planning is so important and like what
do you want to accomplish in that game
and i would be always like terrified of
these questions because i would have no
idea like i'm just moving pieces i don't
know what i want to accomplish and i
would be like sometimes like really
forced to think into planning and then
one day i read magnus book uh maybe you
heard about it it's called like i think
like wonder boy the road to success or
something is by it's written by his
coach um simon agrestine and there's one
chapter called oh i can win a chess game
without having a plan and then there's
the whole discussion how like magnus fe
figure out that like to win a chess game
you don't have to have a plan
and that like called me down and i
figured like i don't actually always
have to have a plan like sometimes it's
about improving your pieces putting them
on the right spot
so the same in life you know sometimes
when we what we set out to be it's not
always what we become you know things
change plans change the same in chess so
like if you think you have one plan like
you want to attack i don't know g7 or
checkmate on h2 like good luck with that
you know i'm going to play g3 we are
never going to accomplish that so we
really want to be very flexible so this
lesson is going to be about short short
term plans just like you know what are
we going to do this week next week and
that's it not in five years just very
short plans
and i'm not sure what is your level
exactly so we're gonna start with some
easiest puzzles and then move it to
maybe some difficult one and there is
also a puzzle that when i was solving it
to prepare for the us championships i
actually was like totally off i had no
clue what i want to accomplish there um
so we're gonna see how
how to even like target like those
difficult positions so here we go puzzle
number one
why to move
my question is
what do you want to do here
what do you want to accomplish
so i'm going to give you like a minute
or two to like you know look at the
material balance look at what are good
pieces
okay i see some suggestions so instead
of telling me moves what you want to do
which some of the moves are actually
pretty cool
tell me like short term plan what do you
want to accomplish with that move
okay i see really cool suggestions from
mark avinash steve
what about here yes okay i see hand
i was thinking um
okay you you thought the same so what
are you accomplishing with this
very good so this you know people could
think here about many moves like maybe
doubling up we thought about bishop d5
knight d5
but the key thing what we want to
understand is that this square is really
important
right and maybe if we jump there
immediately with the knight which is
some of the suggestions we have even in
the chat
this is good but whenever they take
take let's say the king moves it's
unclear what the bishop is going to
really accomplish here
compared to
when we first go there with the bishop
we force to kind of exchange this
defender of the light squares
and then uh
whenever we take takes the knight is
going to be absolutely fantastic here
this spawn is going to be problematic
and then we gonna just you know move the
knight around
we can double up
then we can decide if we want to play
sometimes f4 or if we want to just maybe
move the knight here to attack also this
but we want to um we are getting some
kind of nice position
okay so this was probably a little easy
but this is what i'm going at right we
are not looking at plans like how am i
going to win this position but what is
good now
and again if we go back here
this is another continuation that i
think would be reasonable to think about
but anytime you realize that you can
kind of get rid of the defender of the
light squares that's a good thing
all right position number two and i'm
gonna flip this
because it's actually for black
black to move
what is your short term plan
and actually before that i think it's
always a good good thing to do is just
like taking the position what is
happening
what do we like what do we dislike
sorry tom i cannot throw the mask away
that's a policy here at the club
hello brienne
if you guys can't hear me well just let
me know i will
no good okay
okay so we are kind of seeing this
bishop it's not that awesome yep
what else actually you know tell me what
are you noticing about this position
without first going into any like what
is your plan as black what do you notice
we are noticing this bishop is not that
great what else do we notice
our bishop is also not great i see the
chat is saying that maybe the night
transfer could be good yep so this
knight is maybe also not great and maybe
going here and there could be an option
what else
what else
it's closed position yep
mark is saying i want to improve the
black square bishop but also d6 is weak
yep
what else
you can sometimes you know try to take
like the position of your opponent like
what do you think white wants to
accomplish here
here
in person audience is saying that the
knight would love the
this outpost somehow to
get there probably something like this
but maybe there are other ways although
that's these squares are kind of taken
so
that really leaves this only source
okay
crazy local rooks are not connected for
white yep so white still have some has
some issues with like
figuring out how to finish development
but maybe in the future like doubling up
on dd file and putting pressure here
could be an option
all right i've been actually saying that
maybe stopping f4
hey so if you wanted to really stop it
then maybe you would be required to play
something like g5
but it's a question whether white wants
to do that let's say we play something
like this something ridiculous whenever
white does f5 you know it allows this
pawn to kind of disappear
but then it gives us really nice
outposts and maybe more dark squares for
our bishop
so i'm not sure if white wants to do f4
but if we think white does want to do it
that definitely this is a good move to
prevent f4
all right i think we took a you know
nice one two three minutes to figure out
what is happening
and now it's our turn to kind of decide
what is our short term plan
and i'm gonna move back the rook
okay i'm having some
suggestions in the chat
what about here in person
people
actually even people in chat i want you
now to come up with two moves that you
would consider playing here for black
no plans just two moves
which moves you would consider here
kind of
commit to them in a way that okay i
think i would play one of these two
so how are people committing here in the
club i know commitment is hard
but what is
what is your suggestion here
and by the way chat i see that some of
you have seen like
big preference for one move i still want
you to i still want to force you to kind
of come up with two moves because it's
really important not to have a tunnel
vision so even if you really have strong
preference for one
write another one that you think is you
know maybe second best
yep and here
i'm gonna force you push you
bully you into saying at least one or
two moves
no two moves not two plans just two
moves
it's your turn you have you know 10
seconds now to pick up two moves that
you would play
knight g5
that was one of my move candidates
because i agree that transferring it to
this square is very good
one more move
bishop f8
all right so knight g5 bishop f8 here in
the chat we are say seeing also
a5 or b8
but it seems like a lot of you even in
their chat uh agree with that really the
correct or the not correct i don't want
to say i don't want to say that but i
think the really good move is bishop f8
here
this bishop is not very good we want to
transfer it here to much much nicer
diagonal but also
one very important thing is happening
when the bishop is on 86.
i want you to tell me what
what is the bishop doing there that's
like
really powerful
maybe someone some of you would say oh
it's stopping you know f4 from happening
but what else maybe someone wrote it in
chat and i missed it so please just
repeat it
what is the bishop doing on h6 that's
really important
yep andrew
you get those
you know invisible points
when the bishop is on h6 you are really
stopping
the knight from going to e3 and taking
control of the d5 square
so if the knight cannot transfer to d5
then you are kind of very happy that the
outpost you know it's not being used
let's say they move here
here and then you are just ready to you
know snap the knight anytime it jumps
there
and when you suddenly see this position
maybe black is not that much in trouble
because the rooks cannot really double
here
and if they do so what so you attack
this
um this and i have it defended i can
double if i want to
then i can even transfer the knight if i
want to use the f4 square or maybe you
know then use the king to go here and
push this i may decide and this is not
even you know to kind of argue if white
is better here or black
but to really figure out what's the like
best idea here to do for black because
if you are black and let's say you do
something like
here and i suddenly move this you move
here
i go here
i don't know what you want to do you
double
like you suddenly start seeing that this
may be not like a very comfortable
position because the knight can go there
the rook double
the here maybe even the f4 is going to
happen
and you are going to be like very
shrinked and it's not going to be not
going to be comfortable
why is knight e5 inferior to bishop f8
i think the key is that you are not
stopping this transposition with the
knight
and after this i can always have g3 so
i'm not gonna you're not gonna jump to
f4 that easily and if i'm in time to
transfer the knight here
then i'm very happy
okay moving on
this position white to move
again
take your time
to kind of take in the position
like sometimes we get into the habit of
like searching for the best move and
like what if you are a queen down a rook
up like look at the material there is no
rush
maybe we could make a rule now okay
james is
suggesting a move that looks like pretty
awesome but before you suggest move if
you can do like instead of saying the
move saying the idea that you see
so like here instead of saying that move
that i don't want to mention now here
yet because i think they don't see the
chat here people in person saying like
why is that move good here what it is
accomplishing
and here yep i see what do you think
okay so you want to play c4
and if they take you're happy that the
bishop is going to recapture and
together with the rook is going to put
some pressure
what if after c4 they are not going to
take okay c4 is one move
but if they are not gonna take
exchange
and your
[Music]
i wonder whether we are happy or not
that the file is open you know because
they have two rooks right
but you get also some squares for the
for the pieces i think c4 is a
interesting move candidate yep there's
something better
yep and the chat seems to
get kind of the idea
very well so
what else
what else could we think about the
pieces how do you feel like i understand
you want to play c4 here because you
want to activate the bishop
what is another
like what else do you notice about
white's position
like how do you feel about these two
pieces
because i like i know that you didn't
feel very well about this bishop so you
wanted to improve it right makes total
sense great move candidate what about
the other pieces because that's really
what positional play is about it's about
thinking like being really mindful about
your pieces and just putting them on
better spots
and when we start to think about where
our pieces could be better it
automatically you know forces us to
consider certain moves
that would be awesome to have the knight
there but these two squares are taken
oops
anything else
yeah
so there's one move that's really
brilliant yep what do you think
i'm thinking about
e6 e6
good job everyone in the chat who
thought about this move this move is
really
amazing
because
we think about this bishop and this i
mean this knight and this bishop not
being great
e6 move accomplishes kind of both things
but most of all it gives up
uh
it kind of frees up this square for the
night
and it also like allow maybe when they
take
suddenly this bishop has a target
and in the future this bishop also has
some stuff that you know can be very
dangerous
but now the problem is that this is just
not really problematic because this pawn
is hanging if you go and attack uh
defend the pawn
the rook goes down
maybe this just gonna go
yeah and this is just like way more
comfortable position again you know the
degree to which it is winning or not we
can argue and there is still game to be
played
although i think the chances are very
very good for white but the idea is
there is just nothing better that you
can do here because if you just like
sometimes people are like okay i'm gonna
develop my bishop and i'm gonna improve
my pawn
and yeah i mean
i understand that like you are moving a
little bit forward but you're not really
accomplishing anything
right
so
it's very important i always tell it to
my students and people it's really
important about the moves that you are
making in your game to always kind of
have a short-term plan or short-term
idea like real reason why are you doing
that
uh so here and e6 is just absolutely
amazing so good job
let's move on to
are we ready for this wait let me think
maybe
okay okay let's go to this one
why this one is challenging that's a
warning but i have high hopes for you
here
so i want you to take time
and think what
you want to do here for white
what do you think is good
and why
so again please don't suggest move
suggest ideas
like because with the move unless we get
your idea we don't understand what that
means
but the first thing is kind of take in
the position
calculate the material who is up who is
down is it equal
then what pieces are good bad
and then let's go
um
okay so i see a lot of cool ideas from
you being suggested
a lot of thinking here in the hall
and now i
i want you to just i want to ask you
just what are you noticing in this
position
what captures your attention
even in chat here in the room just right
what do you notice
okay this point is a little bit annoying
right the bishop would be pretty cool
yep
another thing i see bishop e4 with some
queen some ideas here yep
c3 ideas to change the bishops but those
are like specific moves i want a little
bit more
uh from you like what do you notice all
right d6 is weak yep those are the type
of comments i want d6 is weak uh very
problematic right anytime you do you
have a pawn that doesn't have a body
around defending it it's a weakness and
we need to like kind of process that
yep our b2 pawn is also we also have to
be careful so some maybe immediate
actual tactics could be happening here
yep what else are we noticing
yep i see bishop and the rook yep that's
also something noticing
the asics bishop's look a little shaky
and that's what the chat is also saying
the knight is kind of stuck defending
the bishop
also that is the same thing about like
this rook having this open file
right
okay i mean we could talk more
um definitely but now those are like i
think the key points that
they're important to like process before
you even go into like thinking about
what to play
and now what to do
sorry
okay
so fast um
queen so what are suggesting queen g5
that's illegal queen g4 probably
that could be an idea
but then
i don't know if i'm going to do it but i
may just take and take right
queen h5 i think the same thing i just
take and take
we had some
suggestions from nekara he was the first
one seeing like some captures
captures
here
i mean that i think that looks like a
cool idea to you know keep this knight
and attack that pawn
but now if we go seriously about it go
here takes here
defend
um
what's the continuation
like let's say you know takes
takes here
here
bishop e4
i'm thinking about playing this and that
but maybe that's just not the greatest
idea
um
but anytime you take on d6
i just can return with that exchange
right
so if i go like let's say g6 to stop any
jokes here
like if you take
hello to morocco
yeah that
they're just losing some stuff
um
i don't know how you but i'm not
convinced with this
i'm not saying it doesn't have potential
i like the idea
uh but i just don't see how to continue
and you know when i'm
playing a game and i want this from you
as well like if you have a kind of
intuition telling you like okay this is
good you really want to support it by
your calculation because if you just
like okay i feel this is good you go for
it that's not how you improve as a chess
player you want to kind of guide your
intuition and then if just you cannot
calculate that you have something there
you just have to like stop that plan and
move on to something else
and then later in the analysis you can
be like oh maybe my intuition was good
but i missed this move or and that's how
you improve as a player and you move to
different level but you have to like you
cannot just blindly follow your
intuition or your instincts like you do
have to have calculation that supports
that
so here looks cool but
not impressive enough
now this is a really kind of hard puzzle
and
i suggest yeah
and then sure
queen takes them bishop
f4
and if the p moves then we can take the
v8
which is definitely
oh okay so knight takes d6 queen takes
d6
bishop there and you want to take the
knight and then take here
sneaky let's say takes
takes here
so if i go
i have to go queen b6
right let's show it
i think i'm surviving am i
because if you take i'm gonna just
recapture with the rook i'm very happy
and if you push the pawn i can just
retreat
i'm a little afraid don't take me wrong
a little but i think i'm surviving
right
again great idea and you know the thing
about chess is like you want to have all
those ideas that you have like you want
to calculate them but then you only can
play the moves that you are sure that
are going to give you advantage or if
they are not going to give you advantage
they are just good like if you don't see
the end goal that is good for you cannot
go for that variation
like i think really that's an important
kind of maybe even lesson for today that
um just blindly like you know snapping
sacrificing it's
it can help you sometimes and you know
you may win some games but overall
you're not going to really improve too
much
well
i would not have just played that
no no no i mean this was good we were
even like that's why i sometimes even
don't make the moves and when we are
looking with the arrows there that means
we are just calculating in our mind so
yeah no that's totally correct okay i'm
telling you this is the position that i
was actually playing as a practice game
with ray robson before us champs i think
there's even a video on youtube about it
and i totally messed up as white uh i
think i played
i think i played queen g4 queen g3 queen
f3 some of those moves or maybe
yeah and i just tried to like launch an
attack and obviously then i got just
crushed
but before we looked at this uh
solution in the chat they suggested uh
there was uh who was it i think
uh
jj from
slough university grandmaster samuel
something his name is complicated and
alimorandi yes and he was like you need
to see gary casper of sheriff game to
understand the solution of this so i
want to do the same for you let's just
look at this game and maybe we're going
to get inspired
the same way i got inspired only after i
saw that game though so it was kind of
late
so i'm not really interested in this but
look what is slowly happening so we have
like shaving
slash nikov
and i think knight b8 used to be played
here
uh but because of this game people
stopped playing it because
it was kind of like refuted uh but it
used to be played a4 obviously attacking
you know these pawns
rook takes
knight d7 and okay i have some notes
here but now and the key here why this
is just not working was because gary
kasparov came with this really cool idea
which is
rook before
night here
take stakes
and b4
and the thing is that this knight is
like completely kind of trapped
cannot really do much and
i'm just going to show a little bit more
to see how black is just in trouble here
here bishop g5 we may think about
transferring our knight
this is what happened
you see we are still keeping this pawn
stopping the knight from going anywhere
and now the knights are starting to
jump i don't know what are these arrows
sorry
threatening fork
now when the rook moves we want to go to
c4 and really attack the f7 square you
see that like the light squares are just
very problematic this bishop is totally
off
and
you know these pieces are ready to be
doing some damage for a black ink
and now we took back so now
uh we are equal material but this pawn
is just really kind of advancing yep i
agree this guy gary kasparov is kind of
good
the idea is just to improve and
checkmate
and you see it's like it's so sad like
when you see this game it's like this
bishop is not doing anything this rook
is like nice but if you don't have like
other pieces around it's just like
totally useless and like this is just so
annoying these three people here
this is what happened
yeah just exchange up
and
you see you just like take that knight
i'm gonna check my view
attacking moving here and just ready to
push
knight e3 like just like jogging around
having fun gary in this position and
alex issue resigned here
but the key thing for us was um
to take away was this situation when we
kind of
this and then this knight is so bad
that all our light pieces are actually
pretty good so when we go back
anyone having
kind of a suggestion of what to do here
i know so many tactics yep if anybody
wants to go look at that game closely
totally do it
because this guy what was his name
nakara he was actually pretty close
it is an exchange sacrifice here but you
have to be very specific in your first
few moves
no you've seen the game you still don't
see the point
i mean try to improve on your idea rook
takes a6
but improve on that
yep and james just did it for you
so the solution is first
you take which you got the idea
but now you play this really key move
kind of
which is
queen a1 and that's the key move that
unless you kind of find this move uh i'm
not sure how good it is to to sag the
exchange and i mean you can check with
the computer maybe it is
but
um but this is really key because now
what do you want to do as black like if
you move the queen to defend then i'm
going to take this
and then this is going to be a disaster
right so you probably i mean you have
only two defenses and it always hangs
the pawn
so probably you're gonna go back
but then we're gonna go with our bishop
f4
and after move like this like
black's pieces are just like
pretty pretty horrible because you
cannot develop your knight at all
because then it's losing this and
actually now maybe i'm going to take it
anyway because there's checkmate
so you're you're like in complete
trouble what you do here
and you have to i guess give up
this pawn
so what are you impressed i was super
impressed with this because i feel like
i would never like come up with this
solution
but i thought about capturing this
bishop f4 but i just was not impressed
that's why when i played the disposition
out i started i think with like i think
queen g4 i started i re i decided i'm
gonna like sacrifice
if i'm not i decided i'm gonna sacrifice
the pawn
but like he's gonna lose some temples
and i'm just gonna run and whatever run
didn't work but that was my my idea
uh
but just like capturing capturing and
playing queen i won putting your queen
into like a corner like i don't know
that's
just i guess like you know gary kasparov
it's i think it's very hard very hard to
find so but once you kind of realize
it's it makes sense like either you
force the knight back or you're gonna
win a pawn like
you know actually it's not that like
challenging puzzle but i feel that we
are kind of primed of like okay let's go
let's like without kind of stopping a
little bit and thinking
you know if we attack the night we force
the night to go back
so think about the pieces being really
really misplaced
okay
let's move on to this puzzle okay
i hope we have simple time
yeah i usually run like overtime so just
tell me when it's like i need to stop
you want me to tell you when it's time
to stop yeah
okay
just like so people can have dinner and
like have a life
so watch to move here but first again
please take your time
take your time to kind of you know get a
scenery like you know you're watching
something from a mountain like take it
in what's happening what is beautiful
what is horrible
and then we're gonna start about moves
because if you start thinking about
moves now again like that's not a good
way to be solving it because usually in
a game when you play any any like
position you are well familiar with it
because you arrive at that position you
had a lot of plans before you got there
this is just like out of the blue it
never happens in the chess game so take
your time to calculate you know what is
happening
oh i'm happy you guys like the puzzle i
was also very impressed
very impressed with that puzzle
all right so whenever you are ready
again tell me what are you noticing here
this pawn is pretty good
and what can happen with the pawn
i'm just advancing that yeah maybe like
breaking in yep
what else
king is weak i hear here which king is
weak and then i'm gonna go back to
the one thing white king if you displace
the f2 pawn with an advance
or wait no no
wait sorry what was that
no
okay i'm i'm no i'm not gonna ignore you
you're like super active here i have to
be very happy for that uh
uh i'm getting king is weak but which
one white one or black one or both
both kings are weak okay
but which one is weaker if you had to
pick again i bully you into making a
choice
okay that's probably another nice way i
should be nice
if you had to like which king is weaker
white or black
black someone is saying black but that's
one opinion
okay
texas joe the white king is holding it
together
yep i also heard that this knight is
doing a great job defending f2
well there is
f5 so this knight is doing great job
defending uh the f2 the question is for
how long tonight is going to do that
great job
yup
black doesn't have a check yep it's the
king is relatively kind of safe f5 is
scary yep agree
but i also agree with your thing that
this king is weak like i feel like you
know there are a lot of like patterns
you could check made it
um
even like let's say this queen is
somewhere like you know i don't know
grabbing a pawn or something maybe i can
like trade and some checkmates i mean
obviously that's like wishful thinking
but i do feel that this blacking is kind
of weaker
okay so now i think we chatted about the
position a bit and now the question is
what do we want to play
because we see some threads we also see
like maybe we can accomplish something
if we tried playing h4 second the night
and resigning uh
not sure if i want to go with that
knight e3 ideas maybe sometimes yep so
maybe somehow defending the opponent and
reshuffling the knight
yep
actually now when we talked about i want
to ask you who do you think is better in
this position
would you pick white here or would you
pick black here
and yep the
that's actually correct
now chat is saying that this pawn is up
for grabs yep question is whether we
want to grab it but it's definitely an
option
okay white white yeah it's white to move
so most people like white what about
here what do you guys like
because it feels like you you pinch the
right position and collapses right
it could
i still feel that you know this king is
dangerous and we have enough pieces to
kind of attack it but this knight is
really not doing
much yet
so we would like to maybe reshuffle it
somewhere
um
but it's a problem because the knight is
defending the f2 right we talked about
that
so the question is whether we want to
like take
or maybe play something like queen h5
or something else i think king g1 was
offered by chat
do you want this also it's like okay i'm
so terrified i just want to trade queens
make a draw and go home say hi to anish
queen h5 look looks active for sure
okay we have more favor for king h1 here
so queen c5 let's just look at this move
queen c5 is what happened in the game
this is game fun uh for us this super
strong genius from netherlands uh jordan
against stevie turbo
and what happened was queen takes c5
and then there is this strong move kind
of e3
that's what was played
and the problem is that after pawn takes
f3
now we are kicking the knight
and then this king is actually becoming
really weak
so if you go
like
in this book they're like
suggesting like knight f6
kind of being like really strong i guess
you can make a draw if you want to but
now the question is if we can go for
like a win
and that's
unclear but this is what the variation
they are saying here
you know now you have three pawns oops
three points for a night
and they're like okay it's unclear
it's possible
but there is a better move
and that move is that you guys suggested
it's a king g1 it's like very prophetic
move we just don't want to allow this to
happen
so now it's actually not that clear what
to do because if you even
do f5 here now we have this really
strong knight f6 move
it's like really hard to see
i mean we want to checkmate so it is a
forcing move
but it's like crazy because if the pawn
takes
here
king e8
no just like rook g6 like i'm just
waiting you know ready to check my u
and after this
this is like
now i want to play queen d6
it's like such a crazy move because you
want to checkmate here
what if this move who can find the
solution to this move
yep queen b8
there again with queen b8 here and
checkmate
kind of crazy thing so this is like
we are night down but we are actually
winning because this king is crazily
weak uh we had a question why queen h5
is not good
that's a very good question and i think
the solution is after queen h5 i play e3
let me see if we have it here
yeah i'm not sure what you want to play
after
[Music]
either e3 or f5 but let's go with e3
i feel like it was here
just to be accurate if you yeah i think
e3
this this
oh that's a very
wait but i don't have to take right do i
have to take
i can just move
and now i want to
i want to play for win now i mean
oops i want to capture
yeah
so
i think e3s
is just like very now problematic
yeah but i mean queen h5 makes total
sense it's just about like we all know
that ec e3 is like a trouble
and sometimes we're like oh yeah i'm so
scared e3 is really good uh and then we
don't do anything about it and we allow
it right i remember you know a lot of
games like this i had uh because just
move like g1 are just
i mean you have to like have to be
conscious about like okay if i don't
like e3 like king g1 is actually
stopping it and i can still take here
play king h5 on the next move it doesn't
say i can never do that it just say okay
i have to be a little patient
and king g one is the solution and like
the thing is if you go like f5 here yeah
we looked at the knight f6 move which is
really strong
and if you go something like i mean they
are looking at like queen e2
and this but obviously now the king is
very safe and the question happens like
okay do i have some tricks here and
checkmates or not but it's not just like
okay
uh am i actually surviving after e3 or
you know who's better there
any questions about this position
nope moving on
actually
but then i can take the queen
and then i can even
[Music]
yeah i probably just gonna go this
not to give up the queen and hide or
lose a rock yep good question
um all right moving on this is one more
puzzle that i really like
um by the way all these three puzzles
are from this uh
book universal chess training
i bought this book before us
championships to practice i think it's a
very good book um
but it's a little advanced some of them
so i don't know what's your level there
can be different ones but it's a cool
book in case any of you are interested
and just to make sure i'm citing my
sources as i've been taught in class
in school all right so black to move
here and again take in this position and
think about what is happening here
so first what is the material balance
what do you like what do you dislike
i don't like our bishops
you like both of the bishops yeah these
bishops are
not the beauty prizes here i agree
what else
weak g3 pawn yep
huge target for our rock
very good
black has also weak square here so susan
likes white's position
b5 is a past pawn another thing like
it's not that far away from promotion
it's no joke if you leave this pawn
alone
yep
so you know whether you like this
position for black or not
imagine you just made the moves you just
happen to have this position so now we
can you know be despaired and hate our
life and our position and our skills and
all that or we can just put it aside do
that after the game but right now focus
on what we actually want to accomplish
so what can you do even if this position
sucks
maybe not but if it does like
what can i do to at least play the best
moves here
i'm trying to calculate on white's team
so you're thinking about like doubling
up like this perhaps
or sacrificing here
yep
totally something to consider
white queen may be overloaded like
defending this and
that's another things in the chat here
okay yeah i'm getting great suggestions
from chat
um so what about here people
like we can think about capturing here
sacrificing
um
but do we have really enough like
material to do that to attack yeah
right that's so like yes we open the
file more i get it but like we don't
have a knight here or a knight there to
like really you know make it happen make
the attack like really strong so we're
actually going to waste a bishop so the
idea is great honestly i consider it as
well when i was solving it but then i
was like
yeah
for a bullet game good luck but in
reality
it's not very good so what else to do
and yep this
the vibe i'm i'm getting from chat is
this is a position about the kind of the
principle of the weakest piece
and
improving it
so
what is like this is the really the
piece we can brag about all the other
pieces are like
um
but there is one piece that can
like giantically you know improve
if that's a word
where to go
yep
yep
good job on everybody in the chat
suggesting this this is like
2x clan move like it's like weird you're
even returning back to its original
square but you are rerouting it to this
square
and you know taking control of this
diagonal and yep if possible then we you
know we trade we trade the light square
pieces and how we kind of bragged about
all those pawns like maybe if we push d5
and trade something maybe our pawns can
be actually pretty strong if we trade
here right or if this pawn is gonna be
recapturing then maybe our pawns can be
strong so it's not that clear how the
pawn structure is gonna you know turn
around also we do have this file so if
there are not enough pieces or if we
trade this bishop even your idea you
know bishop takes
bishop take h4 can be actually pretty
strong because suddenly there are
probably some pins
right so suddenly like with this like
weird move or bishop c8 move everything
can kind of come up to play and like now
if i ask you which side you prefer like
maybe i'm not sure because this i'm
becoming a little afraid that maybe
white is too advanced
so i thought like other ideas but what i
was considering was maybe something like
d5 because if they take i take
but just nothing is as good as bishop c8
so let's look at bishop c8
uh so what would you play here
now for all those
hating their life for black
now what would you do if you were white
if you had the honor of being white here
what would you play
texas joe likes white okay so texas joe
it's your turn what do you play here
queen f2
so we have queen f2 rule of suggestions
with queen of two and
when i'm gonna play my move
this should be seven
actually good job queen f2 is the best
move in the position just
sorry
um
just to uh what was i think yeah queen
of two is the best because if you go
something like let's say king h2
anyone being
inspired to do something here
yep bishop decades for
bishop take h4
and now we're gonna hit this
so it doesn't work that easily so queen
f2 is a really strong move too also when
you are anticipating this and being kind
of worried about it the best move is
just to move away immediately right not
give that momentum so black and like
it's like a slapping you know you're
scared whenever the slap is gonna come
you want to like okay let's just
let's just not give that you can play it
but then it's not that dangerous
um so queen f2 bishop b7 so what are you
guys playing here
kf2 is also an option
if you want to play king f2
uh
but then i still go here
and if you play like queen h4 the book
is kind of being like really really
crazy with now doing something like e4
maybe freeing up attacking you here
and if bishop takes bishop takes pawn
takes
queen c7 targeting this maybe planning
this
some stuff happening
um but so let's go to our queen f2
bishop b7 so you probably take rook
takes
king h2
and now
important move for black
what do you think you saw
yep d5
we are eliminating kind of the weakness
that we had
and we also think about you know either
taking here and taking here and getting
like a past pair of pawns which we are
very happy or obviously if they take
then they're like ruining their own pawn
structure
and here again we could argue you know
if white is better or black uh or if
it's equal and i actually don't know
i don't even know what computer is
saying that but for me the important
part is that i was feeling miserable in
this position and i figured out how if i
find bishop c8 how to get a game out of
this
you know and that's what i'm always like
trying to now think like when i play a
game i think about short-term plans like
okay what is now happening which pieces
are bad where can i improve them
and i think when we start to be a little
bit more mindful about our pieces we
automatically improve at positional play
because people who always claim like i'm
not good at positional
stuff i i'm good at tactics i'm not good
at you know where the pieces should be
usually my question is uh it's like do
you ever consider like where the pieces
can actually be because if you never
consider it like you never come out come
across those moves but if you start to
be a little bit more mindful about like
okay like here like this bishop is
terrible like let's just improve it
and again it doesn't matter if this
position is lost semi lost or equal this
is probably the best try right
so when we try to think about our pieces
more i think the short term plans just
kind of
you know naturally going to appear and
that's my solution you know whenever you
struggle with having plans or if you
have a coach who constantly you know
asks you about having plans and you are
like clueless what you do then just
remember that like
you don't have to think about anything
like super bright long distance just
like
small pieces small improvements one step
at a time
so i had okay actually this is we have
to finish yeah
yeah okay i had this last position so i
just can leave it here for a second this
is like really cool position i really
like it's from this book play like
grandmaster i don't know who can see it
it's it's really cool um
and was also a position maybe we can
pick up on this one later uh so you can
just think but
that's what maybe we're gonna do next
week as well just looking at positional
play maybe a little bit from different
perspective uh to really think about
pieces
but
yeah i think that's all from me thank
you so much very happy to teach that i
survived and hope you guys learned
something
bye everyone
[Music]
you